this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Mike thank you everyone for
being here today so we all try to
maintain a healthy and diverse diet but
this is not always easy
although nutrient deficiencies are far
less prevalent in the developed nations
surprisingly large proportions of the
u.s. population is - do not obtain the
daily recommended amount of several
nutrients including iron zinc vitamin E
and certain Curt anoints what if I tell
you that we could help with that by
increasing the nutritional quality of
sweet corn and that's what my project is
about
so carotenoids are compounds produced by
plants and some of them have provided me
I provide them in a why Utica criminals
are have vitamin e activities
as antioxidants they might decrease the
risk of several health complications
including cardiovascular disease
age-related macular degeneration which
is the leading cause of blindness and
people over the age of 60 and specific
cancers certain studies have shown that
26 to 30 seven percent of the u.s.
population have low a low amount of
vitamin E and this might be related to
increased risk of cardiovascular disease
how so age-related macular degeneration
affects 6:49 of adults of the age 43
years older and it could be up to 25% if
we consider a hundred and sixty-five and
in general children in the day out the
elderly are the most vulnerable group
for nutrient deficiencies
nutrient nutrient deficiency is rare in
the US but in negative inadequacies are
common this is when you don't have
symptoms but you are consuming less than
the recommended amount and this could
lead to long-term health complications
this happens because seventy-five to
eighty percent of people do not consume
the recommended amount of fruits and
vegetables and I can see a lot of fruits
in the back see also also the
horticultural produce has decreased the
amount of several nutrients in the past
few decades particularly for iron copper
potassium and cows as you can see here
for some of those elements there are a
huge percentage of people that do not
consume this the recommended amount
particularly for magnesium calcium and
zinc zinc and iron
it is estimated a 9% of children and 14
percent of women have low serum ferritin
which is how iron is measure and this
may may us and they might be a risk of
having anemia so biofortification could
help with that and sweet corn is a good
option us is a grade is a major producer
of sweet corn and sweet corn is the
third most consuming vegetable in the
u.s. also some of studies have shown a
great viability for to the terminals and
carotenoids in sweet corn as an example
this study in Australia have shown they
were able to change significantly
changed the carotenoid profile in sweet
corn and the end as you can see they
were able to change the color from
yellow to more orange and that could be
also a good marketing tool to
distinguish the product
you know in the Cremona all pathways are
well-known and several genes have been
identified and to be associated natural
variation in maize here you can see
several compounds for carotenoids and
talk of criminals so for now on I'm
using the colors orange for carotenoids
blue for to cut rhinos and green for
tocopherol and from this pathways the
main ideas to remember is the alpha beta
carotene and beric representing our Pro
vitamin a loosening zeaxanthin were
associated with decreased risk of
age-related macular degeneration
alpha-tocopherol has the highest vitamin
e activity and tocotrienols in general
have higher antioxidant
so the overall go for of my project was
to dissect degenerate the genetic basis
of vitamin and mineral levels in fresh
sweet corn any order to achieve that we
try to identify causative genes and
favor values responsible for a natural
variation and develop and validate
marker based prediction models
to achieve that we use it a diversity
panel with about 400 inbred lines from
public reading programs across the u.s.
the the inbred lines word have mutate
mutate ins in James from the starch
pathway which is particular of sweet
corn the two main ones are sugary one
which is a mutation in this enzyme on
the pathway and those lines accumulate
more vital glycogen which is responsible
for the creamy texture and about five to
ten percent sugar so that's the the
normal sweet corn and then there is the
shrinking tube which is also called
super sweet because it can accumulate
four to 10 times more sugar and
particularly sucrose and it's a mutation
in this gene in the pathway
visually they look quite different and
maturity so you can see the sugar you
want is more glassy type while the
shrunken chew it's it's way smaller the
grain but this is the maturity so we
were analyzing a fresh stage which is
when people consume it and they look
pretty much the same so you cannot tell
them apart just by looking at them
we also genotype we using GPS and we
generated about 170,000 steam markers
information we constructed a PCA and as
you can see there's just weak patterns
of population structure and this is
defined mostly by the star deficient in
despair mutations so there is a small
separation from sharee
- and chug and chew and sugary one but
it's still the variation explained for
PC one is just 5% the panel was
harvested at fresh stage which is about
21 days after pollination and since was
fresh
we flash-frozen using liquid nitrogen we
shall and we ground the samples for the
carotenoids integral criminals we use
they were analyzed in Michigan State and
they we use HPLC we also analyzed the
minerals both for their we use a
different approach and I'm going to talk
to it about this later
using models to estimate the blobs the
best linear unbiased predictors of the
lines you can see that most of the
variation is due to genotype there a
little bit of ear and genotype by
environment interaction for some of the
traits but the majority is genotype and
because of that the heritability are
pretty high as you can see most of the
traits have heard ability of 0.8 or 0.9
so that that's good for us breeders
because it means that it's we can make
more improvement by breeding that of
those traits
correlations also are mostly positive
between the compounds that means that we
can improve one compound and still
increase the other ones together and
this is true even for compounds from
different classes as you can see here
carotenoids and took at rhinos they have
moderate correlations and that's
probably because the these compounds are
all they all accumulated in the
endosperm dr. Froese however accumulate
mostly in the embryo so you can see
there is no much relation to the
tooktook at rhinos for example so that
means that we can target both together
and increase both traits as for health
benefits 1 1 million fresh year of sweet
corn can provide about four point four
point five percent of the RDA for
vitamin E and three point five for
vitamin A this doesn't seem a lot but
several studies in the past have shown
that we can - we can significantly
increase some of those compounds also we
observed that the favorable alleles from
the genes that increase those compounds
they are not all in this in one line so
we are still able to cross the lines and
make and put all the favored values
together so we still have room for
improvement before the sweet point the
main thing is that it's a good source of
zeaxanthin which is one of the compounds
related to the decreased risk of
age-related macular degeneration however
there is no official or recommendation
if we use it the if we use the levels
that was using the they studies that
found the associations the Supplemental
levels which is - you can see the sweet
corn with just a hundred grams you can
you can provide already 50
percent of that and that's just to start
with if we compare two up to the paper
to the study from Australia that I
mentioned before we have here in our
final maximum 1.07 they started with
half of that with 0.0 48 after two well
two generations of selections just for
increased total carotenoids they were
able to get 1.1 which is about what we
already have and later they did more
selection to target just one branch of
the pathway and they were able to get
3.07 so that means that with just one
like a hundred grams which is about one
year of sweet corn you can already
achieve more than the supplemental dose
they also observe an increase in beta
carotene which is really promising
because that's the main provider I mean
a compound even though they did not
select directly for that by doing these
selections they were able to go from
point 2 to point 93
so that's a significant increase and our
panel has about the same as what they
have so that's good for us to start with
so we developed that the we conducted a
genome-wide Association study to see
what genes are responsible for the
natural variation here you can see the
Manhattan plot for the ratio of these
two compounds Delta 2 gamma took at
Rhino which are here in the pathway we
found no association close to this gene
VG 1 which is located here right before
each of the compounds we also analyzed
alpha tocopherol which it has the
highest vitamin e activity and we have
one significant a marker within the gene
that is right before alpha tocopherol so
it's responsible for converting gamma to
alpha tocopherol something particularly
off this panel is that we found
Association of the starch genes we took
at rhinos which accumulate in the
endosperm as you can see here the tube
variously are close to sugar e1 and
shrinking - that I mentioned before and
we also found association with AGG t1
which is responsible for producing
precursors for all tocotrienols so it
makes sense to have association with
Tata tocotrienols when we classify the
lines the according to de the air
endosperm mutation type we notice
therefore tocotrienols the shrinking two
lines in generally have higher Delta and
gamma took a trial one of possible one
of the reasons is from one of the
reasons it could be because most of the
lines are fixed for the favorable you of
the aggg one gene so that means that
they already have the favorable allowing
that ug for that gene and they are
producing more precursors however even
we free compared just we think the same
have the same allele we can see the
shrinking two lines is still accumulate
more so
Katrina's then sugary one lines so that
that indicates that there might have
something else going on there however we
could not we could not test that because
of the confounding effect that about
this that most of them have are fixed so
in order to study that we are planning
to use ISO lines so they have those are
lines they have the same background they
just are different in the gene of the
they start gene mutation so we can
compare the accumulation of those
compounds and also RNA expression and
doing that we expect to see if they do
have any direct association with the
levels of Tokat rhinos
in the literature however we have found
some studies in our abductees that by
increasing sucrose they were able to
increase the activity of the enzymes in
the math pathway so by increasing this
this pathway they were able to produce
more precursors so our hypothesis is
that by having more precursors these
lines would produce more took at rhino's
but as i said this is something we still
need to to test although the we don't
have a good explanation for the sugary
one lines we we think that those
associations with death region is just
because of the high OD the linkage
disequilibrium between the two genes
because most of the lines I won't have
one one endosperm mutation or the others
so that kind that that's why we are
seeing those associations
four so white lines they don't have they
have Loker tonight content in the
endosperm so if we consider if we do for
example use it phenotype just a binary
phenotype white versus yellow we will
find a large effect close to this gene
psy 1 and this is in this part of the
pathway so that means that depending on
the allele for the gene the line doesn't
produce any of the carotenoids there so
in order to study did the quaniee
quantitative variation we we excluded
the white lines for the carotenoid
analysis so for the genome of the genome
I Association for heart anoints we found
for beta-carotene which has the highest
provider being a activity
we found one association with we are b1
which is responsible for the graded
beta-carotene to transform into beta
cryptos ending and further to Xia's
ending for the ratio of betas on to fuse
and beta 2 alpha zento fuse which are
located here in the pathway so this is
the alpha branch and this is the beta
branch we found one large association
with like you want which is here in the
pathway and it's responsible for
changing the flux to one branch to the
other so depending on the elio you are
gonna have more alpha xanthophylls or
beta and in our inner Opena we actually
notice that most of the lines have the
favored value for the alpha branch so we
have room to select for the lines that
favor this branch we has which has
beta-carotene and the essent
other than G was we tested genome
prediction models too as an approach to
force genetic improvement a sweet corn
using a GPA up with about 170,000 as new
markers we were able to achieve
prediction accuracies about point 5 to
point 7 for carotenoids or in for to
talk to corals and point 5065 for touka
trainers
because we saw association with the
genes in the starch pathway we tested
putting that information in the models
to see if there isn't any increasing the
accuracies in the predictive abilities
as you can see here for tocopherols and
alpha toget rhino by including the
kernel type in the model there's no
difference however for a delta and gamma
took at rhino we saw about 5% increasing
the predictive abilities so that means
that this information is not being
captured by the whole by whole genome
wide asleep markers and these are the
same two traits that I showed before
that there was a difference between the
two classes of lines so we use it we use
it the genome prediction models for the
main carotenoids in poker criminals to
select the best 20 or 25 lines and we
separated in the two classes of this
permutation and we use it the the genes
that we identified in G Wars and we
score each of those lines to see if they
had the favorable or the least favorable
value in that gene so we had the three
genes for toko criminals and two for
retinoids and here in this table the
light color it means it has the least
favorable you and their color is most
favorable as you can see there is no
role with all the best combination for
those genes so that's our job as a
breeder we then cross lines with
complementary traits complementary
alleles for example I would come up
cross this one to this two rows so in
the end we expect to select lines with
both favored values in those two genes
so far we have made over 150 crosses and
they were self and we are gonna start
validating the models in the near
future
as a take-home of this this section of
the presentation we have identified
genes for in the pack the pathways for
took a criminal and carotenoids pathways
especially like u13 RB 1 VT 1 & 4 & 8 g
GT 1 we also saw some associations of
sugar e1 and shrinking tooth took a try
nose and that's the thing that is most
like the most different thing from my
project there was not reported before
we also showed that sweet corn has that
great has a good contribution of
zeaxanthin which is important for
decreasing age-related macular
degeneration the risk of that
capabilities were wandering so that
means that we can use those models to
select the best lines and the first
process were already made to increase
soccer criminals and carotenoids
for the second part we study di anomic
switch it means the mineral content of
those lines because that is more is
associated more with environment and
then there is a high genotype by
environmental interaction we use it the
same samples but we had an extra
location so we measure here in New York
and also in Wisconsin the the lines the
kernels were layer flies and then we use
a icp-ms to measure individual seeds
individual kernels as you can see here
there's a similar plot that I show for
the criminals genotype still has a grave
viability is responsible for most of the
viability but now you can see a lot of
environments playing a role and some
environment genotype by environmental
interaction still the her abilities
worldwide it will moderate
so for iron zinc for example is point 63
and 66 so it is still good good enough
for increasing by breeding
as correlations they are mostly positive
between the the nutrients as well
particularly for the ones days have
similar chemical properties such as
calcium and strontium here and magnesium
and phosphorus were high too and as well
as iron zinc and that's probably related
to the transport and accumulation in the
plant because several transporters of
iron for example they are the same for
zinc one thing that one down point of
this is that phosphorus was positive
correlated to zinc and this is no idea
because phosphorus is mainly a
accumulated phytic acid in the kernels
in fatty acid is known to decrease the
bioavailability of iron zinc so that
means if you are eating a grain with
lots of iron but it has also fatty acid
they might you're now going to be able
to observe as much
when we compared the values between
locations you can we can see that there
are differences between the locations
but there is no trend in favor of one
location or the other for most of the
the nutrients so some nutrients were
higher in one location and the others
were higher in the other iron zinc think
there was no difference and iron even
though there was a small difference
you can still see viability in both
places
for the genome-wide Association you
study for this traits we found
significant associations for zinc and
iron in the same region and this is
close to an I hope Tian mi synthase gene
in a s5 so it is any hair na s is here
and it's responsible for producing Nyko
Tian mi so this has essentially Chu it
has two functions it serves a precursor
of magenta acid soma genic acid is used
for grasses Rubinius plants when they
have deficient they are deficient to
iron or zinc they secrete these
molecules in the soil and these
molecules form complexes with iron zinc
and this helps them to up to uptake in
the roots another another function is
that they serve as they are important
matter
acha laters so they form home the
inequity nmi form complexes with in the
plane and I responsible for transporting
and there are basically two types of
enzymes DNA s so there is class one
which produces the inequity an amide
which is used for eugenic acid or for
long-distance transportation and there's
class shoe which is more related to
homeostasis and iron detective
detoxification if we see the the enzyme
that we found the gene that we found
association is na s5 and this is that
class Chu enzyme so that indicates that
most defoliation that we are seeing are
mostly due to the redistribution of iron
within the planes so basically going
from leaves for example to the kernel
another
Association we found was if admin and
this is close you I have metal at EPA's
if we see here in the roots tell Ken
moon after being and entering the cell a
form complexes with fight Ocala teams
which is here and this complexes are
then sequestered by HTM a tree which is
the Association we found so that means
that some plants are able to set
sequester though the Ken moon in the
cell roots and then that Canyon is now
transported to the Colonel's one thing
to note is that although we saw a
variation for CAD moon in suite point
even the highest accumulation
accumulated one it still accumulates
just really small amounts if we consider
the the toxic amounts of cadmium for
people the the line that accumulates the
most it would provide you just 5% of the
maximum that you will have with one year
so it is still really far we to be
worried for now but of course if we
increase iron zinc we should still keep
track of cadmium to make sure that's not
an issue
we also analyzed the concentrations
within each each location to see if
there's any specific association for
malignant
we found one association in chromosome 1
which we don't have any candidate genes
so far there is there was there is this
known transported of malignant in the
same chromosome but it's quite far so
you can see that we we had some signal
there but we were not able to we didn't
have enough power to detect
we also found a cessation of Nikko in
New York and this is close to PTR two
which is a peptide transported so
peptide transported they transport
mostly nitrate malate and histidine and
it's also known that nickel binds with
the CD histidine with high affinity and
there was some association of histidine
in the detoxification of Nikko in plants
they accumulate a lot and a lot of Niko
so although we did not find a direct
association between the distance Poirier
with Nikko we hypothesized that this
transporter might be transporting become
a complex of Nikolas histidine but this
is just this is what we are thinking
that could happen with you
we still need to test and for Wisconsin
we had one specific association close to
this gene rest room so rest like gtp
aces are regulated by calcium dependent
mechanism and some small gtpases were
shown to influence costume channels as
well so that's a life that's likely a
candidate but also another thing that
could be happening is costume is high
highly related to correlated with us
junction which is another matter with
similar chemical properties and in the
Nessun association mapping of maze they
found one significant association in the
same region pretty close to our marker
but that was for instruction so we're
still not sure if there's association is
particularly off with calcium or
something related to
we also use unum selection for this this
elements and as you can see they were a
little bit lower than carotenoids and
Tocco criminals but they vary from low
to moderate and the two main nutrients
that we are interested in which is zinc
and iron
they had above-average predictive
abilities
and they are they were mostly associated
if her abilities so the more horrible
traits they had more predictive
abilities we also tested the kernel type
to see if we could increase those
predictive abilities and in this case it
was he did not change it reactive
predictive abilities for any of those
nutrients as you can see here and one
reason for that is that differently from
carotenoids into Petrino's which
accumulate in the endosperm most of
these elements accumulate in these two
telling of the embryo which is this
party you are seeing the colors here so
for most of the the elements you don't
see much in the endosperm there is a
little bit of for potassium but it's few
you can see that it's blue so it's low
compared to the biscuit alum here
as a take-home of this part we identify
several genes that are associated with
iron zinc in as5 Cadman or HMA three and
two associations is specific to Nikko in
New York and council in Wisconsin we
also noticed that sugary one and
shrunken chew they didn't have a big
effect on those nutrients not it was not
as pronounced as carotenoids interpret
Romano's and iron zinc they don't do not
seem to have the same genetic control
schedule so that means that we we could
increase those two elements without
increasing cannibals so that's a good
that's good for us and we saw moderate
predictive abilities 4044 eye rinsing so
this is just a first step so far we have
used the prediction accuracies in our
results to select line for curtain
reason to go criminals so we were able
to start the breeding program well in
the future we expect you use the rest of
the results to increase even more other
nutrients as well so we want to have
like fresh sweet corn with more
nutrients in general
I would like to thank the committee
members my committee members the my
advisor Michael Gore Margaret Smith and
Gavin sax also the whole gore lab which
helped a lot with the field trials so we
all went to the field and helped
planting and harvesting so particularly
Nick asthma which was always responsible
for in charge of the few activities and
Jenna for taking care of the project for
now from now on as for all our all our
collaborators from different
universities my funding Cornell and
Kappas and all my family and friends and
I think my mom is watching an Internet
thank you for your attention and I would
be happy to answer any questions now
[Applause]
tell me my green side images the
pictures you showed but they were
slightly sad so do you think it's just
environment or our needs or adapted
genotypes or do you think that face the
question is can you get all these
subscribe now and so they're all dreams
into more leap turn possible sweet
crunchy sleepless refreshed record speak
more like yeah so the question was about
the appearance if we could transfer
those nutrients to or more appealing
speech born lines so the thing is that
we those are inbred lines and they
usually they look really bad and if you
they are really small and they the
pictures that I show they're all hand
pollinating so they were manually done
so there's a lot of variability the
video
who did it and the year so there for the
open pollinated ones they look pretty
good and if we plant those like those
would be hybrids and we expect you have
better like better quality so that's the
main reason no the question was if there
is an upper limit that we should take
care to nah go beyond and so for vitamin
a def probably not because the plants
they don't produce vitamin A it reduces
carotenoids which are pro vitamin A so
it's converted to vitamin A in the human
body so if you eat too much protein like
your body we would just not confer to
vitamin A so that's not that would not
be an issue and for vitamin E I by
looking at the numbers that we have I
don't think that would be an issue also
because so far it's still quite low like
point 4.5 so I would I would think that
we could would be able to increase like
to 15% like 20 I don't think you would
go and then a hundred percent is why we
you need so you still have a lot to go
over to increase like to go to upper
limit so I don't think that would be an
issue yeah yeah most of the most of the
talk toxicity of those vitamins is when
people take superman's they usually did
not come from from consumption
you had the one association with a ratio
between the two branches and I guess my
question first is did you in you test G
was for that ratio because you knew what
the what the biochemical pathway was and
therefore it was sort of a priori
motivated and if that is the case how
would you go back to finding those types
of associations if you don't know if
you're working on summits have like if
you don't know the biochemical pathway I
mean in four is it yeah so the question
was why we use the ratio and why we
having in mine and Wow
if them if we didn't know that before
why we would have done so yes the we did
use because of we knew the pathway and
because a previous word have the use the
same the same ratios so if we don't if
we didn't know the pathway I think I
would first like look at what other
people did in the area and look for
correlations to see if they tend to to
accumulate together or see something
about the biology for example for the
for the nutrients the elements they are
not part of a pathway they are all
separate but they are correlated like
they are in a coal network so what we
did we did test just two ratios of iron
zinc / phosphorus and that's because we
know the phosphorus could be decreasing
the bioavailability of iron zinc so what
we had in mind was trying to test the
best combination that like we had more
iron but let less phosphorus so that's
what we try to do for the ratio so it
depends it depends the while you you
want to test
[Music]
you are interested in accumulating I
love little iron smoothness but if your
concerted I have availability of you're
using phosphorus what would have been
validated that an appropriate proxy for
my availability and as course it really
you had a way to think of composition
what way would you what would you choose
if you want to achieve higher and higher
and then before than a lot of it what's
the right way
could you make more matter okay so I
wish I had a good answer for that but so
the thing is it was validated that it is
a proxy but it's not perfect like it is
we know that 90% of the phosphorus is in
the form of fighting us and in those
kernels and we know that there is a true
association we fight a acid with by
availability it's not one-to-one but
there is association so the best way to
to test that is using k kochu or models
for example where they actually tested
by availability but in our cases we
didn't have that the best way was to use
the phosphorus as a proxy but and
concerning about what I would do I think
I would try I would try to decrease the
amount of fatty acid but just it needs
to be done just in the seed so there has
been some studies in the past that they
did that so you cannot decrease
phosphorus in general because maybe that
phosphorus is needed for the termination
of the seed later
so some of studies they decrease the
amount of fatty acid so most of they
changes the same enzyme so the
phosphorus Minh keeps as phosphorus or
inorganic phosphorus instead of fire
acid and that's best for the
bioavailability but I also that needs to
be done just in the seed because fire
acid is good like it's usually the whole
plant so if we change the whole plant
there other things that might change too
so Mike the quick answer would be like
trying to decrease Friday I said
especially in the seed but still keeping
similar levels of phosphorous it's in
the same it's unfortunately it's in the
same region of iron zinc so it's in the
embryo yeah so the question was about
cooking how it how the nutrients are
after cooking
so actually carotenoids they are more
available after cooking so there's there
has been some studies that after cooking
they they are more you you are able to
use more than before cooking and for the
nutrients there has been some studies
that the fatty acid is broke down also
so in theory it's iron zinc would be
more bioavailable because they are still
there but then phytic acid is broke
breaking down and then they are not
forming complexes together so in general
should keep similar or be better
actually
you should some know information where
you added a kernel type in as a
predictor of it they look like you were
reciting the minutes additive makers you
know it secretly took of criminals that
right there might be an interaction
between the kernel type and how it goes
chameleons internal in other words some
kind of is having interaction between
the kernel type and the rest of the
genome or accumulation yes so that's
something that's actually what we don't
know and we so far we cannot test with
the Planum that we have because of the
confounded effect because most of the
lines they have the favorable alleles
for those genes so we cannot compare it
with one or the other that's why we are
planning we have like two or three
backgrounds like eyes aligns with
different backgrounds and then we can
test exactly that to see if there is any
interaction between those genes and
genes from those pathways so so far we
don't have an answer for that pigments
so there is Bill Tracy which is from
Wisconsin and he has been doing that
actually he was able to have what he has
a new line now it has more into signings
which accumulates more like a purple-ish
it's the still he has a new line and it
does look pretty nice it's like it's not
the whole year it's just like a couple
kernels but the there is some the hard
part is that anthocyanins they are
accumulated later in the maturity so
when it's maturity it looks pretty good
but then when it's fresh it it still has
some color but it's not as dark and the
other thing that he noticed is that
after you cook all the color leashes out
so it
nice if you are like buying but in the
end it's more like appealing for buying
you don't when you're eating you're not
gonna see a lot for now but that he
might be able to improve that yeah it is
good like I do try bran it was okay so
at least for the vitamins but most of
these pathways are pretty well described
and so I guess my question is would what
was the justification for doing
genome-wide scans as opposed to just
looking in region right so you could
have said okay we know that these 25
genes are in this pathway let's tag
those regions with the snips that we
have in them right in that spot just
test those stairs Dan and additionally
did you by doing these genome-wide scans
did you detect anything that you might
just using you know so the the question
was about the reason why we retested the
same we didn't test only like the
candidate genes so I have two good
answers for that
one is that we would not have found the
start genes because we wouldn't never
think about those as candidates and the
other thing is we did test genome
prediction with snips only close to the
candidate genes and the predictive
abilities were quite low compared to two
using genome wide so the Ford Focus
rhino's you would drop like 10 percent
or less so we still think maybe we don't
have enough coverage in those regions
but then and yeah it's base
with that I think we don't have enough
coverage and maybe other genes that are
also being have a part of that so the
main reason would be finding like new
associations other than actually
unrelated follow up the starch genes is
is the is the association that you found
like just associated with the fact that
they have less starch higher
concentrations or we talked about that
and we did include kernel weight and
like moisture anything Nassim to explain
because there's a high difference in
weight but is that maturity so a fresh
kernel the weights are pretty much the
same so there is a difference it's about
one gram like one milligram difference
but when we use in the in the models it
did not explain imagine as the
prediction abilities alone if you just
use things from the kind of genes but in
your slice there is a major loss I'm
sure you know firms are passwords why
would you not I think by MIDI I need
transcript factors that may affect her
much pathway Oh a factor specific
pathways in your studies the question
was why did not find associations if
other transcription factors that affect
that yes so I think the main answer
would be probably we don't have enough
for ability independent because the most
of the lines are derived for a few lines
in the past or we just didn't have a
power to the tech like maybe it's like
smaller effects and we didn't have a
power to detect those
and public not yeah and then the name
population has five thousand we have
four hundred so I do not expect to find
half power to the this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu